So after depressive for yest, well,
we've had emotional foil bullish Kate,
and now we're going to go on to Peter Hitchins
member of the international socialists,
not now until 1975 columnist
for the mail I throw.
He thought you were extremely a Trotskyite
colonists for do walk up. As I'm talking on the mail on Sunday,
occasional broadcaster and author of several books,
most recently the phony victory and, uh,
attracted to both parties, uh,
but now belongs to none at all.
Peter Hitchins lift our spirits.
Yeah. Uh, good evening. Uh,
I I'm here actually swayed you to the virtues of gloom
and this, this, this, this, this, uh, Kate's, uh,
optimism is a SOC optimism is a,
is a terrible code for living and one's always ended on happiness.
It's being pessimistic. That keeps me so cheerful. Uh,
I want to, I want to, first of all,
explain to you exactly why it is you should adopt gloom. Um,
by saying it was a brief story about, uh,
a welder working late at night in one of the old shipyards we used to have in
Clydebank and no longer do working so late that he was probably the last person
in the dark working on our other precarious piece of scaffolding on the side of
perhaps an ocean liner. And as he prepared to leave,
suddenly the scaffolding gave way beneath him. And he fell many,
many fees until eventually he grabbed onto the side of the dock and below him,
perhaps 200 feet of concrete and then a puddle of oily water
and nobody to be seen. So he called out,
is there anybody out there?
I know Voss subcultural voice came from very, very far about saying,
I am here my son. And he said,
what shall I do? And the voice said,
let go. And he said, is there anybody else up there?
I am the Sapulpa voice. I am telling you, let go,
let go of your illusions. Uh,
let go of the ridiculous fantasy that we have, that we are a rich, powerful,
important country. Uh, many years ago,
Dennis Healey said that we should probably get used to being an Island. Austria.
I wish that we could not look forward to anything as stable and prosperous as
that, but even so it might be wise if we began to understand just
how precipitous our full has been.
I grew up at the very of the empire. I was born in the empire.
I was a subject of his majesty King, George, the sixth.
And I was born in Malta than the headquarters of the now non-existent
Mediterranean fleet of the Royal Navy.
And I saw that the concentrates slightly in the next few minutes on two things,
one of them railways and the other, the Navy,
because they dominated so much in my childhood.
The Britain of those days was full of wheezing, clanking, panting,
steam engines with names like six Oh one squadron and Winston Churchill.
I've saw of much of my life,
great gray warships gliding in and house of Naval bases.
So I was moved by these things.
I would just tell a couple of brief stories here about how these things have
changed in not in my lifetime,
but in what you might call the recent lifetime of the country in 1,906,
the greatest advance in military technology of the era,
the construction of HMS Dreadnought,
the first really heavily armored heavily gun battleship,
which completely changed the Naval arms race.
And the balance of power in the world was completed in one year.
And one day in Portsmouth, dockyard from the laying of the keel.
So the finishing and launching of the ship,
it took 14 months before she was actually steaming in
19, in 2007,
the then labor government ordered the construction of atrium as queen Elizabeth,
the new aircraft carrier looking very much like a multistory carpark afloat,
which will be obsolete by the time, uh, sometime next year,
14 years after it's the United States of its construction.
By the time it actually obtains an aircraft,
that's one example and 1836,
the bill or run the act authorizing the construction of the great Western
railway from London to Bristol was passed by parliament offered longest stroll
immediately without any aid of JCBS or any kind of modern technology or
electronics in bought kingdom,
ruined L coop commenced to construct what was then the most advanced.
And in some ways still is the most advanced piece of railway line from London to
Bristol. It took him five years by contrast,
what is known to travelers like me on that line as firstly Western, uh,
began to electrify it so many years ago,
that I'd forgotten how long ago it was ran over budget to a colossal extent
and never finished it. These seem to me to sum up in many ways,
the contrast between the Britain that was and the Britain,
which many of us still fondly imagine we still are.
And the Britain that is one which was competent, effective, capable,
and efficient, and one which is not sloppy in capable of, of,
of completing or indeed devising anything worth doing this
extends into so many things. And Kate spoke of our freedom.
I don't know why she spoke of it in such,
in such how should I put it in a few sort of terms? I,
I took some time studying this apart from Michael how's the salt on the rights
of silence, uh,
and William Hague's and Anthony Blair's assault on the
laws against double jeopardy and prosecution.
We have in my lifetime pretty much dismantled jury trial.
Majority verdict means that the independent jury is really no longer in
existence. I make ceaseless attacks on civil Liberty,
on every conceivable occasion on the weakest possible excuse. I was,
we used the other day and he wants to take him out to think about this.
When I saw a headline prisons to introduce
airport style security,
this means that people who've been convicted of quite serious crimes, murder,
theft, armed robbery, that kind of thing. Uh, finally now on arrival in prison,
going to be subjected to what you innocent persons have to undergo when you want
to fly to Paris, is this the right way round on the country?
It's an indication. And when you, when you fly anyway, which I try not to do,
and you have to have your testicles scanned by a revolving machine and your
luggage search and be treated as if you were a guilty person.
This is a country in which the presumption of guilt is now pretty much
universal. And that is where we live. And the idea that we're still a,
a beacon of freedom seems to me to be fanciful, begin to freedom. Well,
I was at school, it was generally Stacey,
the deceptive English a levels were equivalent to an,
to an American university degree.
And this is one of the reasons why there was then a thing called the brain
drain,
where the United States spent an awful lot of money scooping up the Prolex laws,
the,
of our extremely effective and excellent state grammar schools to go and work
there. So what did we do?
We abolished the of schools and it created in the name of equality,
probably the worst state education system in the advanced world
whose certificates are multiple and many people have large piles
of them, but which are in relation to the,
to the education available in this country 50 years ago,
much as a 10 billion Martin note was in relation to a golden silver.
They are spectacular, but worthless.
And our education system isn't national discretion is one of the reasons for
many of the deep problems that she had, um, which,
which we have been unable to face and have attempted to overcome with amongst
other things, massive immigration.
Most of the other vainglorious statistics about, uh,
being the, what is it, the sixth or seventh largest economy, ah,
actually based on, on, on more fantasies. Um,
our actual position in GDP per capita is roundabout 26th in the
world. Uh,
our current account deficit is pulling, uh,
levels of public and private debt are pretty much unprecedented in peace time
and are simply unrepairable to imagine for a moment that this couldn't
possibly end well is to be self diluting.
And the ultimate symbol of this hubris is a
ridiculous pretense of being a great power.
We are a country which could not defeat a collection of gangsters and
protection, racketeers, and surrendered to them in 1998 in Northern Ireland,
still pretend to be a world power and maintain and propose to extend and
renew the Trident nuclear weapon, a gigantic cold war,
superpower weapon, totally useless to us, which we cannot afford.
This is the symbol of all the hubris, which we possess.
It is absolutely everything that is wrong with this country.
The fantasy that we are more important than we are the fantasy that we are
richer than we are the fantasy that we stand for anything much anymore,
all things,
which we'll never let his death will never under any circumstances be put right,
as long as we entertain these delusions.
And that is why it is so important to say the things that I'm saying.
I'm not just saying them because, because I've been invited to say them.
I am saying that because I believe them to be true.
I'm saying that because if there is to be any future for this country,
which I frankly, seriously doubt,
then it has to be achieved by recognition of reality.
I love every field in hydro of this country.
I was brought up to believe that it was a beacon of all kinds of wonderful
things, which I see rotting away.
I was brought up pretty much to know by heart John of Gornstein speech,
but what do I see, uh, th th th this country,
which was weren't to conquer other Seth now made shameful conquest of
itself.
And it is because we need to recognize this reality that I urge you so very much
to vote for this motion. Thank you.
[Inaudible].